bonjour theofanis angelopoulos merci
beaucoup d'être en direct ce matin avec
nous sur rt france le pari est de faire
de ces îles grecques des îles co-lead
free alors expliquez nous la démarche
bonjour madame alors je vous parle
d'athènes
le concept est assez simple en fait
c'est d'eysines qui seront de moins de
1000 habitants qu'ils aient tous les
habitants sont vaccinés et puis sur
ligne il y aura en fait les les
les voyageurs et les gens qui vont êtres
vivants qui m'en allais sur cette île
les visiteurs pourront circuler dans
toutes les il y aura les fournisseurs
seront tous vaccinés où ils auront des
des tests qu'ovide régulière et aussi il
y aura la possibilité soit que les
visiteurs sont les poissons soient
vaccinés soit ils auront des tests pcr
négatif et puis après ils seront aussi
tantôt examiner tous les deux fois par
semaine on pourra voir que il reste
négatif comme ça il y aura une libre
circulation dans tout l'est nord est
puis un salutaire
voilà exact ce serait les x rocco big
three et puis s est des îles qu'ils ont
que même une superficie assez
importantes comme ça les gens seront
libres de passer leurs vacances pas dans
ce parce qu'il ya aussi ce concept dans
d'autres doigt mais c'est des endroits
qui sont ya des restrictions ils sont
que dans le dandé dans les stations
balnéaires il dans des hôtels et ses
traits sais c'est pas du tout en se on
peut pas ressentir cette liberté qu'on
pourrait ressentir sur cd le grès avec
des belles plages l'objectif l'objectif
justement c'est de vacciner 70 % la
population est ce que c'est le cas
aujourd'hui
est-ce que vous avez suffisamment de
doses justement pour parvenir à cet
objectif
écoutez c'est l'objectif pour la grèce
est de vacciner ce sont 10 % de cas ça
c'est vrai mais sur ces îles la les
les habitants sont tous vaccinés ya le
100 % des cas est 100 % des habitants
sont fait vacciner
c'est pour cette raison que ces saisines
et en plus à part ça on a aussi le la
mesure de deux parce que vous connaissez
que même avec le vaccin on pourrait que
même attrapé ce virus
alors du coup avec les avec les rapide
test où les tests pcr régulière or on
est encore plus sûr que c'est il reste
country durant toute la période des
vacances c'est l'ouverture prévue
justement au tourisme c'est donc un
joueur de moi de te voilà le casse mais
voilà lui même exactement
et c'est le cas ouais c'est le cas pour
les sites sont prêtes
yahia c'est surtout dans ce concept qui
aura 69 villes participantes mais là il
ya déjà une quarantaine d in avec les
habitants qui sont tous vaccinés
entièrement le lille et les habitants de
ces titres sont tous vaccinés
c'est très important cette mesure parce
que justement on le sait l'économie de
la grèce dépend beaucoup du tourisme
c'est un enjeu majeur
exactement ça c'est vrai que on a on a
quand même ce ce privilège d'avoir un
endroit qui qui est féerique vous faites
qui est très très beau et c'est à cause
de ça que la grèce a misé sur sur le sur
le tourisme je pense que la grèce c'est
la californie ou la floride c'était et
puis où sous les caraïbes en fait c'est
un endroit qui est proche d'eux
de france et en même temps un endroit
qui est vraiment très agréable en ce
sens dépaysé en ce sens dans un antre
facile d'accès en fait
merci l'accord ceci ressemble beaucoup à
à la grèce est depuis hier s'acquiter
qui est expérimenté depuis ce matin en
corse en tout cas merci pour votre
optimisme theofanis angelopoulos qui
fait du bien dans cette crise sanitaire